laborers in new delhi work through
temperatures above 40 degrees celsius to
construct india's new parliament
buildings
like many street vendors and auto
rickshaw drivers here they make up some
of the 75 of india's workforce who work
outdoors
we have to go outside to work it's very
hot even the water we carry becomes too
hot to drink we don't even have enough
water
a heat wave has gripped many parts of
india for weeks that's after the nation
saw its hottest march since records
began
122 years ago
the higher than usual temperatures have
led to demand for electricity reaching
an all-time high this week and power
cuts in several states delhi's regional
government has told people to expect
power outages at metros and hospitals
because of a shortage of coal at power
plants the indian government has
cancelled hundreds of passenger trains
to rush coal to thermal power plants
around the country
the intense heat has also affected wheat
crops with some agriculture experts
predicting this year's yield will be 25
percent less that could have
international implications india was
planning to help fill the gap in global
wheat supplies left by russia and
ukraine we also know that 55 countries
were dependent on the food coming from
the baltic region and 55 is not a small
number so if you can't be standing along
with another 55 looking for you know
beach supplies next year so i think we
have to be very watchful and careful
meteorologists say the severe weather is
part of a reoccurring trend you notch
the temperature up so when you get these
heat wave events they're becoming more
frequent they're more intense and when
they happen they last longer so we're
definitely seeing a shift in the trend
to more intense heat waves happening
in this part of the world
the indian meteorological department
says heat wave conditions will continue
in several regions in the next five days
but there's little respite expected
afterwards with may and june usually the
hottest months of the year elizabeth
puranam al jazeera new delhi